here's my first example so have a look
at it um you've got a mass of four kilos
it's um something that i haven't written
there maybe you want to add is that it's
dropped from a very great height
okay so we're considering air resistance
right now
air resistance is proportional to
the speed and we're calling the speed v
now
please know this is just one of the
reasons why you have to be careful about
how you define your positive and
negative
you'll frequently see this and for me
when i first encountered these questions
this was maddening because i was like
why are you calling speed v can you tell
me why that's a weird decision
to me because v you usually indicate
it's velocity
which is uh which is a vector has
direction in it whereas speed is not now
it turns out that this is actually
critically important
that we consider it just as positive and
we take care of direction by doing
this okay so this number here despite
being called v
it is the speed and i don't know what
it's it's it's always going to be just a
magnitude so i don't know about the
direction
um the question will often say the
constant of proportionality
that describes what this relationship is
and then they'll give you a number
okay so let's simply talk about how this
and this are related to each other
in other words the air resistance is an
eighth of whatever your speed is
okay was there something else i was
going to mention
so yeah would gravity be meters per
second squared instead of music
yeah of course oh i remember what i was
going to mention
um what you will find is for these air
resistance or water resistance questions
that kind of thing
you will pretty much have one of two
things air resistance or whatever
resistance will be proportional to the
speed or it will be partial to the
square of the sphere okay now just just
think for a second
when do you think you would get the
square of the speed versus just the
speed
this is still this is still like talking
about the speed
itself not worrying about velocity at
the moment we'll get to that though
it will define it will change which um
which expression you use for
acceleration
i'm just thinking more physically right
if you're proportional to the
square of the speed rather than just
affecting a proportional to the speed
does your speed
mean more resistance or less resistance
as your speed increases it's more
right clearly like whatever effect
you've got it's being exaggerated
okay so basically this power like
there's no reason why it has to be one
or two
we're just doing it to keep our algebra
and our calculus simple
as your power goes up what that refers
to is how viscous the material is that
you're running through
okay so what you'll have is sometimes
you'll have a like a weight and it's
dropped in like a mud swap
okay so that's super super thick very
very viscous so you're going to get
something like v squared
whereas air we tend to just stick with b
okay so four questions for you i wonder
if you can make a start before i start
to hold your hand through it
i'm looking for velocity as a function
of time
after you've got that velocity time
function can you draw for me what that
looks like how is the velocity changing
as time progresses
can you find terminal velocity that's
what where this will come in
okay and then lastly you had velocity in
terms of time can you find displacement
in terms of time
and in reality a question like this
would usually go to like okay well
therefore when are you at such and such
a place but we'll just stop getting the
function
okay so here are all my clues here all
the things that you need
to find a positive for me no it was
dropped from a great height so i'm just
going to say
the mass was dropped make a stop
draw a diagram and say that and uh
i'll let you get a couple of minutes
head start before i show you my solution
okay you can sort of guide me through
how do we even start this
okay now i'm looking for a velocity time
expression function i haven't finished
my diagram yet but i've made a start
you can see i started from up here i've
defined down as positive and the
particle dropped from the origin so this
is my
starting point up here oh okay so here
is the particle at a particular incident
time
now i have some forces acting someone
tell me what kind of forces i've got
okay so gravity right gravity acting
downwards get used to i mean we've
already written this a couple of times
gravity is always influenced by how much
mass you have okay so
mass times gravity which is going to be
in this case
4g okay hope the reception is good up
there
okay now you've got mass times gravity
acting downwards
but you've got the opposing the
resistance opposing you right
so up here just as a customary way
because it's proportional
right that means it's this times some
kind of constant okay now i'm just going
to write that as k
v i'm not even going to bother defining
k because they've defined k
it's an eighth okay so i've got here
and a v right now because i've got
arrows on here indicating direction i'm
not going to say that's
negative n8v even though it will be once
i write my equation
this is what's telling me what's going
on okay by the way down here you might
notice
i've drawn my axis there and then
there's my positive displacement
on that arrow okay so so far so good
i've got my diagram now
what might be the first line i write
i'm just going to write that now i heard
someone say resolving forces
uh in this particular example i don't
need i won't need to this is why it
doesn't appear over here i won't need to
resolve any forces
when do i need to resolve forces what is
it that makes
force resolution necessary on an angle
yeah it's when things are like off in
funny directions
you're like there's a horizontal bit and
there's a vertical bit and i need to
kind of sort them out
but here everything is simply up down so
luckily for us no resolution required
okay
i always like to start with this because
now i can use that to explain from all
of this information
what my next line will be okay so
we'll start with the easy side which is
the right hand side i know what the mass
is
it's 4. now i've got a whole bunch of
different ways to write
acceleration that i can choose from okay
now just for the sake of it over here
can you help me remember acceleration
how many different ways can we write
this let's just start with the easiest
one i've already got on the board
i'm just gonna say a first okay don't
don't ignore it sometimes you just leave
things in terms of a because that's fine
what might i do next okay so i've heard
a couple
so i'm gonna go with x double dot first
i mean there's no real order to these
but i think this is like the simplest
the simplest ways okay next double dot
remember what do the dots mean by
definition why are they not dashes
i'm differentiating in a particular way
with respect to
time right so this is really a shorthand
way of saying
this okay i've got one two three how
many do i have left
three three three so so give me the next
one
okay so because you're the second
derivative of displacement that means
you're the first derivative of velocity
okay last two the trickiest ones
okay d on dx of half v
squared and last one okay
good so i even though it's i mean you've
got this on the reference sheet all that
kind of thing
but i kind of like to write these out
because it helps me work out like
what's my next step i just have my
choices laid out here right
now think about where you're going you
know where you're going which is the
most obvious choice
i want v and i want t right so i think
i'm going to choose dv
on dt that's mass times acceleration
okay um i will point out it's not a zero
why is it at zero
why is it mass times acceleration why is
it zero it's a thing
this is this is a function that varies
what would make it be zero
if that would do stationary if we're
stationary or
moving a uniform straight line now i'm
not there yet there will be a point
where that's zero but i don't know what
it is yet so i just leave it as is
okay so now i refer to my diagram what
forces i acting
on my object on my particle
one of these is positive and one is
negative okay we tend to write positive
things first
so so yeah this is the positive one
because i've defined
down as positive and this is my negative
one
does that look good yes lovely okay so
now from there
what we suggest i do next dive
oh hold on a second so i'm going to
pause just so my numbers end up
the same i don't know why i did this
sorry guys in this question they said
mass pipelines
um that's not going to change very much
it's just the concept
but that way my numbers will agree with
what i worked on earlier which is always
a month
ah thanks okay
so now seeing where i'm going right
seeing where i'm going
what kind of computation do i have to do
here i'm looking at their puzzle
something not up not right oh you
changed the mask
that's fine that's okay that's right yes
well it's just gonna be
80 just well 128 you'll be 80 percent of
me
okay mostly uh okay so i'm going to
divide through like it's just the
constant yeah it's just the constant
so i'm trying to get to dvntd because
then i can
get it i'm going to integrate so i'm
going to shift this over and divide
through at the same time
that gives me this or perhaps
1 and 32 okay from here
what's my next step i have to take the
reciprocal because
all in terms of v okay so i'm just gonna
do one thing before i flip which is turn
this into
a single fraction right common
denominator so this looks like 40 g
take away v on 40. okay
now i'm ready to do a reynard so
there i go come on don't worry so arena
is only when you go to one
side oh i see okay so i did it properly
um so here we go i've got this now i'm
ready to integrate
now i will point out just like yesterday
at this point if you want
you could put in a definite integral
here if you know like
you've got conditions here like at time
zero
can you tell me some things that we know
at time zero um x equals
zero okay good because it was just
plot wouldn't x be the height of the
building ah
now it depends entirely on how you
define it okay and i will define it
differently later
but i've defined the origin as where it
got dropped from right so
up there like you said the first time
it's x equals okay
so far so good and now i'm going to
intro i'm going to stay with the
indefinite integral
i don't know here i'm very happy to do
the definite one if you like when i
integrate this
okay now you may like to write this uh
40 out the front what is this thing
okay so this is going to be a log but
look because of chain rule in there
there's a negative that's going to be
out the front
so this is negative 40 40
minus big plus or cos c okay
so i'm pretty much there and just watch
out times zero
um when i put in time zero this thing is
non-trivial the cost is not just gonna
become zero it's gonna become something
so you can see if i put in time zero
velocity zero because it just got
dropped okay so if i've got zero here
and zero there that's a negative right
so that's going to go over the other
side so what would the constant be
40 log 40 g right so
when t equals zero you can do your
substitution and i'm going to right
there
you'll get this constant or 32d